[Música]
trouxeram suas mochilas
sim porque vamos precisar mochilas
a jornada será muito grande será muito
intensa durante minha fala
pode ser que alguns detalhes
perturbadores é e algumas simpatias
possam provocar novas emoções fortes mas
no final todo mundo vai chegar são e
salvo beleza de onde vem um chileno
qual o legado de onde vem a inspiração
de poder provocar jovens a transformar
suas vidas pela educação
qual o sentido de tudo isso onde se
colocar no poder transformador que essa
ferramenta que há mais a mais valiosa
que nós temos para poder percorrer o
estado o país
quem sabe o mundo de onde vem o chileno
a minha história é parecida com a
história de todos os jovens no brasil
e aí se você parar pra pensar o primeiro
livro que você leu
talvez ele tenha começado com era uma
vez
essas histórias de príncipes e princesas
sempre tem essa grande frase que nos
provoca a se perguntar um de era uma vez
como era uma vez porque era uma vez e
foi aí que eu comecei a vislumbrar ea
poder de alguma forma encontrar como os
grandes bolsas grandes saltos que a vida
dá eu nunca pensei em percorrer chão
estão batidos os lugares por onde eu
percorro as cidades onde o vôo o estado
que eu nasci o estado que eu nasci
as cidades têm chão batido no chão de
terra mas rachados jovens com sonhos
foi nesses caminhos que eu comecei a
encontrar qual o verdadeiro sentido
segundo schiller e aí eu nasci nesta
cidade uma das cidades mais lindas do
estado de alagoas
junqueiro nessa cidade rodeada de
cana-de-açúcar eu me encontrava todos os
dias com a perspectiva de ter a minha
vida transformada exatamente pela
educação
eu nunca gostei de tomar banho na
verdade ou de tomar banho não é um banho
pra mim é uma coisa é um caso mal
resolvido da água comigo comigo para com
a água e aí eu ficava me perguntando
será que isso nunca vai parar
será que isso nunca vai parar e todos os
dias quando acordava de manhã eu olhava
ao redor da minha cidade ao redor da
minha escola e via que junqueira rodeado
de cana de açúcar
e eu dizia meu deus somente será esse
nosso nosso legado nosso caminho nosso
futuro não quis não seja digno claro mas
existe um jovem que poderiam colocar
potência das eleições dentro de uma
mochila e tem a vida transformada pela
educação para pra pensar
são mil flexões de coluna por dia numa
jornada de 12 horas de trabalho e aí a
história do banho se complicavam quando
acordava que eu via o pó da
cana-de-açúcar entrando pelas franjas já
te da minha casa se instalando no chão
que na minha pele
olhava pra minha mãe dizer trono janeiro
e tomar banho
mas eu olhava pra ela e ela me dizia
simbolicamente se você tiver muita sorte
você vai para a irrigação é uma história
bem comum
nosso estado é uma história mais comum e
aí pra completar a a jornada dance
grande legado é eu não conheci meu pai
não conhecido de fato não tem a imagem
dele não tenho um semblante não tem um
super herói
alguém que vai levar para a escola
alguém que vai representar e aí como
preencher esse vazio e os meus amigos
brincavam desenhar o nome de seu pai ele
sei n sei eu iniciei como assim é um
rapper não
n sei não consta isso perturbou por toda
minha vida até que eu resolvi colocar a
educação como forma de preencher esse
espaço
até que resolvi colocar os professores
da minha escola para preencher esse
espaço
todo processo que eu via ele indaga olha
quer ser meu pai que se no bairro até
professores decidiram ser meu pai por
algum tempo ea escola estadual padre
hélio góes foi o espaço onde eu comecei
a perceber que não estava sozinho lutava
sozinho tem outros jovens com mesas
perspectivas e com o mesmo sonho tem a
vida transformada pela educação quando
você nasce nesse ambiente que é o estilo
que é desafiador que é provocador como
encontrar forças para ele transformar
como fazer isso de forma a se motivar
para transformar como é essa história se
confunde com a história de muitos jovens
hoje que a gente percorre aí no brasil
eles usam empatemos essa história é
minha a história pode ser a sua pode ser
a sua
pode ser de um jovem que você conhecer
simplesmente um livro e depositou nele a
esperança de um dia ele poder chegar e
dizer olha acredite a educação salvou
minha vida no mundo existe jovens
aí como o na cota em que ele tem vida
bem distinta o que esse jovem representa
simplesmente quer ser um guerreiro né
ele nunca saiu da aldeia dele e ele
simplesmente tomar conta destes animais
aí ele faz isso de uma forma valorosa
na verdade o que ele queria de fato era
poder ter a sua lições toda transformada
toda realizada
eu escrevi uma instituições assim como
ele escreveu eu amarravam e sistemas
todos os dias ea minha primeira mochila
hoje é grande enorme pensões livros
legados a minha primeira mochila uma
bucha supermercado eu colocava os livros
ia para a escola com ela e todos os anos
eu pegar essas bolsas e encarava os
livros cava bonitão ficava muito legal
assim como esse jovem a voar como um
pássaro em seu homem mais rápido do
mundo podem encontrar num carro
horizontes
quando você não tem nada quando não tem
nada e quando você consegue de alguma
forma transformar e catalisa ensinada
para tudo
taí uma das coisas mais simples
eu acho que todo mundo aqui vive uma
hoje com a maioria de vocês e ele nunca
tinha visto um marco
e aí você começa a pensar em si poderia
dar passes 11 o planeta empatia começa a
se colocar no lugar daqueles jovens que
você vai lá no interior
e quem tem a oportunidade de conhecer
escolas destruídas lugares sem vida sem
alma sem perspectiva e seus sonhos
lá faço mínimo que você conseguir fazer
alguma forma você vai ver que você vai
estar dando horizonte fraqueza jovens
possam voar voar e transformar aquilo
que ele tem de mais importante que não é
dinheiro não é bens é a vida tá aí um
dos vídeos que eu mais gosto que mais
representa aquilo que a gente está
fazendo hoje né
um dos vídeos que mais representa o que
a gente está fazendo hoje
e aí eu comecei a perceber o impacto da
escola na minha transformação rubem
alves tem um poema que ele simplifica
tudo que a gente sente quando nasce
lugares em cidades distantes em cidades
distantes do novo distância da
informação há escolas que são gaiolas e
há escolas que são azuis
e à minha escola particularmente falando
eu volto todos os dias nela quando eu
tenho a oportunidade para poder dizer
essa escola fui asa para que eu pudesse
alçar vôos
então não existe nenhum poder
transformador não existe nenhum impacto
por mais simples que você queira causar
se não passar por a escola se não passar
pela base
se não passar pelos líderes que são
aqueles que vão respirar durante sua
jornada no meu caso os professores e aí
eu comecei a perceber que a escola
estava me dando asas para que eu pudesse
voar para que eu pudesse ir lá e
transformar esse ambiente um ambiente
democrático
o ambiente vital o ambiente que me fez
entender que além da fumaça das
queimadas de cana de açúcar e dos sonhos
colocados em mochilas para ir para a
entressafra no paraná em alagoas
isso mesmo jovens fizeram muito meus
amigos jovens eram muito
existe um ambiente que poderia
solidifica aquilo que estava sonhando
aquilo que estava percorrendo construir
a história mais comum no brasil o
primeiro a terminar o ensino médio o
primeiro a terminar o ensino superior
quanto as famílias têm esse legado
quando as famílias se emocionou quando
vêem olha meu filho ter na universidade
foi o primeiro
então eu percebi que existiam muitos nós
durante essa minha jornada e quem está
de tennessee para perceber agora o laço
do tênis sempre inicia com a firmeza de
um nó a beleza de um laço no cadarço de
um tênis e sempre inicia com a firmeza
do noel era preciso entender que não
existia somente nós para desatar
mas nós pra consolidar para dar firmeza
para poder construir aquilo que vos
apresento hoje
ao desembarcar nas escolas existe as
palestras existem os livros a gente
desde um livro como legados para esses
jovens
mas a fala de três coisas super
importantes que eu gosto muito de poder
compartilhar seja com os professores e
com os alunos tecnologias educacionais
e aí é baseada em livros em plataformas
como cláudio sá site da geek e também
como caio devido caindo no brasil a
gente tem a possibilidade de poder
encontrar nessas tecnologias
educacionais novas formas empodera
jovens pela educação de tornar o ensino
mais democrático e de alguma forma
ampliar o processo ensino aprendizagem
nas escolas a educação empreendedora
esse foi o grande estar diz que eu tive
quando eu estava assistindo a uma
palestra do fernando dolabela e aí foi
onde tive a idéia de poder imaginar um
mundo de conhecimento um mundo de
conhecimento no interior do estado no
interior do brasil pode ser um chuveiro
poder se entenderam e levar tudo que
acontece nas escolas nas universidades
de alagoas da capital de maceió para
poder colocar isso pra percorrer o mundo
e apesar de significativo
não leio muitos aos antunes é um dos
caras que eu mais goste quando fala
sobre aprendizado significativo nos
conceitos de multidisciplinaridade e
interdisciplinaridade adoram poder
debater discutir isso nas escolas por
onde a gente vai além de poder inspirar
a impactar jovens
eu procuro também moveu um legado para
que professores e educadores possam
experimentar também esse novo tempo que
a educação tem como transformar na
mochila existe um sonho seus impactos
mas a minha mãe é doceira e eu ficava
olhando pra cozinha dela todos os dias e
dizia porque é que as pessoas gostam
tanto do seu 12
se teoricamente aparentemente é igual à
das outras pessoas que fabricam e ela
dizia
descubra descubra e eu comecei a
percorrer a cozinha dela
e ver quais eram as ferramentas que ela
utilizava eu percebi que nenhuma
ferramenta prática técnica seja filtro
seja clarificador seja a batedeira
formas nada disso fazia o menor sentido
se ela não utilizasse amor e ela disse
coloque-a muito tudo que você faz
mochilar pela educação é mochila por
amor é colocar o semblante olhar da
minha mãe quando dizia muita sorte
irrigação muita sorte
a universidade não precisa mais de sorte
agora transformação desenvolva
desenvolva encontro líderes encontra
pessoas que preenchem um vazio não
consta
e aí você consegue vislumbrar e perceber
que são os grandes interiores nos
pequenos lugares que existem as grandes
idéias que existem as grandes pessoas
que podem transformar o mundo que
existem pessoas que estão sonhando
exatamente com o que eu sonhei anos
atrás esse legado de uma mochila e aí
tal mochileiro
pra mim a coisa mais extraordinária
desembarcar em escolas de forma social
sustentável mas social como é que você
consegue fazer isso em tempo de
distribuir livros entrarem nos lugares
são de gente - imagina como fazer com
que jovens se ouçam e procure entender
quais são as ferramentas que você
utilizou para chegar tão longe
são jovens do ensino médio crianças só
não cheguei a beber ainda que com essa
barba e assustar os meninos e todo mundo
foge vai explodir tudo
marie sair um pouco do que a gente tem
feito nem um pouco do que a gente tem
desenvolvido um pouco do que a gente tem
procurado de forma compartilhada de
forma coletiva é deixar para o nosso
estado para o nosso país
a gente trabalha na base mochila para
mim é uma grande diversão mas a inversão
com conceito
uma inversão com foco uma diversão que
tem realmente um objetivo é percorrer a
seguir
e aí eu precisei realmente estar
preparado pra todos os momentos que
anteciparam as jornadas na escola
indígena
talvez tenha sido meu maior desafio
porque o pajé de sole não prometa nada
ainda
senão a gente vai cobrar e eu prometi
livros e eu tinha medo de ficar lá no
tronco e eles me deixarem eu prometi
livros e prometeu uma palavra que
pudesse transformar a vida deles
ah então aqui tal grande ingrediente de
uma jornada o grande ingrediente dessa
jornada na verdade é amor é quando a
gente procura colocar aquilo que a gente
tem mais intenso tem mais verdadeiro
aquilo que a gente faz tudo tudo o que
fizerem assim como minha mãe faz faça
com amor procure potencializar aquilo da
melhor forma possível parece romântico
contextualizador romântico contextualiza
do parece que você fala fala e nada faz
e aí eu convido vocês a cada um de vocês
a colocar a mochila nas costas ea poder
um dia somente um dia os livros que você
tem casa que não utilizam mais e vão
percorrer essa jornada pela educação
comigo
nelson mandela quando estava preso
quando ele estava preso ele escutava um
poema vitoriano que encerrava com a
seguinte frase seja senhor de seu
destino seja capitão de sua alma esse é
o legado da mochila
vocês podem ser que vocês quiserem os
jovens do interior de alagoas e do
brasil podem ser que eles quiserem
utilize a ferramenta educação encontra
líderes e sejam ciências capitães sua
alma
senhores seu destino muito obrigado boa
tarde
[Aplausos]